now the government unveiled a new co bid
alert system back in May a 1 to 5 system
which shows the current level of the
current virus threat and the action that
should be taken as a results what level
are we currently on we're transitioning
from level 4 to level 3 we've made
steady progress to get the are level
down below 1 it's still below 1 it's
between 0.7 and and and 1 so it's below
1 no point 7 1 or point 9 we've you look
at the data if you want to really see
what the trend is showing us if you
compare last Friday's data with the
previous Friday so over a week we've got
over 800 fewer new cases over that
period we've got over 200 fewer people
in critical care with coronavirus i
think their deaths are down over that
period by 27 that is the steady progress
that we're making which means as we
transition to step 2 on the roadmap to
easing restrictions we can take those
steps responsibly but we just have to be
very careful as Jonathan van tam who you
just quoted is said we're a precarious
moment we can ease up we can protect
life but also livelihood to get life
back to something resembling normal but
we must monitor it very carefully and if
there's any uptick in the number of
cases if we stop making the progress I
describe we're gonna have to take
further measures again and target the
virus wherever it may appear so we're
making progress obviously this is a
sensitive moment but we can't just stay
in lockdown forever we've got to
transition and the more we transition
through careful steps the more I think
we'll build up confidence in the
approach we're taking and very briefly
beginning the answer you said that we
were transitioning from level 4 to level
3 so I'll take that as confirmation that
we haven't yet reached level 3 because
according to the government's alert
system when you're at level 4 the
current level the action that should be
taken is the current social distancing
measures and restrictions but you aren't
maintaining the current restrictions are
you from Monday you're beginning a
gradual relaxing of the restrictions and
social distancing measures that's the
action pegged at level 3 so why
following your own advice on this well
as I said we're transitioning from four
to three an hour that alert system is
obviously decided independently by the
scientists we have at every step along
the way followed the advice not just of
the deputy chief medical officer that
you cited but Sir Patrick valence I
spoke to so Patrick over the weekend the
chief scientific adviser and the package
of measures we're taking is based on the
advice that we get from Sage obviously
we as the elected politicians we take
the decisions but at every step along
the way we've taken that advice and the
reason that we can take the steps that
we're taking tomorrow to start getting
more primary school children back to
school to start taking the measures to
open up the economy on car showrooms
outdoor markets is precisely because not
just the our level is down below one the
way I describe but also because we're
making the progress on the data as I
described and all of that is very
carefully scrutinized and we we rely on
very carefully on the advice from the
scientists you see it's hard to escape
the view that you thought it would be at
level three now it's not saved desired
to plough on anyway
no we've said that we were transitioning
we set out a road map we've set very
clear conditions for moving first of all
step one which we took earlier in May
then to step two which we plan to take
and we will take tomorrow and then there
are further steps along the way but
we've always said we'll follow the
scientific advice there are strict
conditions that we need to see fulfilled
they have been fulfilled the our level
is still below one the death rate if you
look at the trend data is coming down
we've got the testing and tracing system
we've got 25,000 traces that have been
recruited we've started already their
testing and tracing we got the capacity
to make sure that 10,000 new cases
on a daily basis that we can trace the
the people that have been in close
contact with all of those cases so we're
making all of that progress that we
describe and that's the basis on which
we can proceed to step two tomorrow you
say that you're following the signs I
mean that's really been the mantra of
the government all along but let's be
honest let's you know treat people are
adults scientists disagree the
scientific isn't advice isn't definitive
and when we've seen that in the last few
days when members of the own if the
government's own sage advisory committee
have come out saying that they disagree
with the easing of the lockdown measures
why don't you just be honest and say
that look this is a political decision
you're weighing up things like the
economy versus suppressing the virus and
actually it's you they get the
politicians who news take responsibility
for this not the scientists well
certainly we want to be based on the
scientific evidence you're right to say
that the scientists won't always agree
that is actually the essence of this age
group there are at any one time 25
scientists that are participating
there's a whole range of other subgroups
and other expert advice that they get
and it would frankly with a new pandemic
it would be totally surprising if they
all agreed in uniform unanimity they
don't that's why we have that group to
test the evidence to test the scientists
views based on that evidence and then
you're actually right we as elected
politicians have to take the the final
judgment call that's inherent in this
process as it is with all pandemics and
all countries around the world and then
just finally on your point about whether
it was some kind of trade off between
the economy and public health that's not
the way we view it we are overriding
priority is to protect life but we also
know that we've got to protect
livelihoods jobs the economy because
that props up all of our crucial public
services and so the steps that we're
taking it's not some binary trade-off
because of course if we had a second
peak in the virus we were going to end
up back in lockdown and that will be bad
for public health reasons but also for
the economy we have more protracted
economic pain so we're taking measures
now which are based on both the public
health considerations but but they're
also crucial for the economy and we're
taking shortage steps and we can take
the second step so
because of the progress we've made but
but but it's true to say the scientists
do not always agree in fact that's
that's not what we want we don't want
them all to agree we want them to test
the evidence that's the way we get
better advice from them and and yes
absolutely as elected politicians we've
got to take the judgement calls and be
responsible for those one of the
concerns that some of those scientists
have raised in recent days is that the
test and trade system is effectively
untested it's only just got up and
running a professor John Edmunds saying
that relaxing the lockdown with an
untested track and trace system I think
we're taking some risk here so jeremy
farah said test trace and isolate has to
be in place fully working capable of
dealing with any surge immediately now
there are 8,000 new covert 19 cases
every day in England according to the
Office of National Statistics that's a
fifth highest in the world that's not
counting those in hospitals or care
homes at what level what level of daily
coronavirus infections do you think the
test and tray system can actually deal
with well the international experience
and we've also had previous pandemics in
some of those countries that are ahead
if you like in the way you described on
the test the tray system had previous
pandemics so they had that learning that
they're done but the experience both
from those pandemics and from around the
world is that actually the majority of
testing and tray systems work most
effectively when you're and and can deal
with the strain for the volume of cases
that you just described once you're
coming through the peak and once you've
got the virus down below a certain level
which is why we've at Kate's been
building up our tests and tracing
capacity we've got the 25,000 traces
recruited that work has already begun
they have the capacity to check 10 the
contacts of 10,000 cases each day and
we're also getting the planet in be app
we've got the the pilot on the Isle of
Wight all of these things are in place
so we will strengthen it reinforce it as
we go but the system is already up and
running and that is part of the reason
and the calculation as to why we can
proceed to step two on Monday
you can see why people are nervous they
were head of the Monday when that step
two will be released we've got eight
thousand new infections a day that's a
high level of infection still an R rated
between naught point seven and naught
point nine just a little under one an
untested contact tracing system has only
just been set up an app that is still in
a pilot are we heading for another
resurgence no as I described and I set
out at the start of this interview the
number of new cases Friday compared to
the previous Friday is down by over 800
the number of people in critical care
with kovat 19 is down by over 200 the
death rate if you take the trend data is
is coming down and it's because of that
progress that we can take the steps
where we're taking tomorrow but you're
right that people should be cautious and
one of the the things that the
scientists have said to us is that we
can take these measures but people must
still adhere to the revised social
distancing rules and the guidance that
we put out so yes we we are cautiously
proceeding and yes people do need to
follow the guidance but we are confident
that this is the right step to be taking
at this moment in time and of course
because we've got the test and tracing
system up and running in effect where we
see any upticks we can target our
approach very carefully and that's the
whole point of the test and tracing
system so that we've got control of this
virus and we can continue the pressure
to keep it coming down as we take those
cautious sure-footed steps forward both
on schools on the economy and also you
know you look at the people that have
been shielding over two million people
that have been shielded are elderly
people with a particular condition and
we understand that very responsibly very
carefully but they will feel the need
and want to come out and have some
outdoor exposure to be able to go for a
walk outside so we're taking those steps
and the guidance on that will be set out
by the community secretary later on
today we're taking those steps very
carefully based on the science but also
based on our ability now to monitor the
virus in a way that we haven't had
before and that's a tribute to the work
at DHS see getting the testing and
tracing system up and running and we're
continuing to look at reinforcing that
every
step along the way so just quickly
before we move on to our other issues
will the lockdown be tightened again if
you can see infection rates increasing
we will target if there's any uptick
whether it and it could be in a locality
it could be in a particular setting we
will target very carefully measures that
would apply to it so that we can take
these steps but also keep control of the
virus and that's certainly the capacity
that we now have when with Testament
racing and all of the other knowledge
and learning that we've done that's the
ability that we've got now and that's
why we can take this step in a confident
in a responsible way on Dominic Cummings
and when did you first find out that
Dominic Cummings had left London and
travelled to Durham I'm not sure but to
be honest with you when the story broke
was when I first became aware of the
detail of it and the reason I'm asking
you is because the Prime Minister was
obviously ill at the time that Dominic
Cummings made the journey Boris Johnson
testing positive for coronavirus on the
27th of March it was around the 30th of
March that we believe that Dominic
Cummings wasn't Durham and from the 5th
of April you deputized for the prime
minister when he was ill that's before
the trip to Barnard Castle that Dominic
Cummings made so while you were the de
facto Prime Minister did you know that
Dominic Cummings was in Durham I just
knew he was out of action because he'd
come down with coronavirus and to be
honest with you so far I'm sure you'll
understand given the scenario we were in
with the Prime Minister taken ill and
and very seriously ill as it later
emerged I was just focused with the
government with a great cabinet team or
making sure we continue to focus
relentlessly on dealing with the virus
so that wasn't something I mean I knew
Dom was unwell and he was out of action
and that officer wanted him and the
prime minister to get well soon but I
wasn't focused on his movements at all
and I wasn't aware of them just to try
and get the new straightforward facts
about what happened because of course
you were acting prime minister at the
time so I do think it is quite important
what's the first time you knew that he
went to Durham when you
need you then I wouldn't be able to save
with any precision I want to give you a
really accurate reliable answer but I
hadn't at the MIT at the time I wasn't a
aware of it other than as I said to know
that he was unwell I was out of action
and to be honest with you I didn't
inquire as to his own personal
circumstances I was just getting on with
the job so you didn't know
frankly I didn't know did you know not
at the time no okay thank you and
there's a couple of other Foreign
Affairs stories I'm keen to get you on
while we happy foreign secretary we have
seen the protests in the US over the
death of George Floyd we've all seen of
course they pretty horrific video the
police officer standing on his neck now
Donald Trump said that if those
protesters had breached the White House
they would have been greeted with the
most vicious dogs and the most ominous
weapons I've ever seen earlier this week
he tweeted when the looting starts the
shooting starts is it acceptable for the
leader of a country to be talking in
those terms about his own citizens
Sophie I'm not gonna start commenting on
the commentary or indeed there the press
statements that other world leaders may
call or indeed the US president what I
would say is that obviously as you said
that footage of what happened to George
Floyd was very distressing as has been
the scenes across America of the the
rioting and some of the violence and
what we do know is that the lead suspect
has now been charged with murder there
is a federal review and we want to see
the escalation of all of those tensions
in America come together some sometimes
though you do need to comment on the
statements made by other leaders though
don't you we will comment on actions and
stuff there's material to the
relationship we have but I'm not going
to be drawn into the questions of
whether the u.s. president's remarks
were the right thing to do I leave them
to comment on their own domestic
policies why not
well I think all it does is create a
distraction from all the things that
we're doing we're working very closely
with the US on coronavirus on many other
things and frankly it becomes a media
distraction and I want to be focused on
the job at hand okay and just finally
and foreign secretary Harry Don was
killed last year after being hit by a
car driven by the wife of the US
intelligence officer who then claimed
different matic immunity 19 year-old
Harry Dunne now his family want to bring
a private criminal prosecution against
you saying that you do not have the
authority to allow an sakuni's to return
to the u.s. so did you in the Foreign
Office act properly and Northey so look
first of all that's a family that's
really hurting my deepest sympathies are
with them we're on the family side I
want to see justice for Harry Dunne and
we cleared the way so that a prosecution
charges could be brought and we've made
clear to the Americans and I've
discussed the case recently with my US
opposite number that that we we remain
deeply concerned and dissatisfied with
the way the Americans have approached
this we think an circulars should come
back and face justice in this country
absolutely in terms of my own the
private prosecution story I'm not gonna
comment too much on it other than just
to say I'm confident that I've and the
Foreign Office and the government have
proceeded lawfully and properly
throughout this but you know we
understand that this is a devastating
time and ordeal for the family and we're
just doing everything with it
we can to get justice for them